you got your prospective Cobra try to
make some money what up my guy are you
nice to meet you Gary sure nice nice
real pleasure how are you
love those right let's have to
appreciate it everybody's constructing
right Kari
my god one bother you yeah man go do
your thing we have so much so much brand
stuff to talk about and Super Bowl
there's so much money for all of you to
make throwing Super Bowl yeah just on
Airbnb yeah you just move out for like
four use your book a hotel now and
Airbnb your [ __ ] out and make like five
g's it's Super Bowl is going to be the
stupidest thing ever
everybody's coming
100%
you
for mrs. already air for girls and boys
crazy this is a nice [ __ ] space
cramping your [ __ ] of course I know you
separate them so like the a room right
here right here right here nice how do
you man there's a parking lot nothing in
the middle and then you notice a like
almost like the Sony lot like a baby son
is like and then I can go back and I can
put my two film studios back there
how old are you man I know exactly what
you're trying to do I've been watching
record smart man people got 87 pairs of
off whites but no property push does it
even like coming up in the culture just
around like nothing howdy young cast
like it's just great and I was a young
cat making beats and I'm saying or
whatnot
no no I knew different young carousel
photographers artists whatever you're
nursing but we never have her space I
really never have liked her Plus this
market was it wasn't mature yet
like what Atlanta is now compared to ten
years ago are you kidding this is the
epicenter of the game this is the
leverage you guys have you were 29
already here you don't get it it's why I
took advantage of the Internet
because when the Facebook and Instagram
Whannell that should happen I was
already grown I was 32 33 I already had
like the experience I saw that show
you're gonna you know something's gonna
happen whether it's with artists it
could be some new music genre it could
be something and you're gonna be like
wait a minute
this is the same [ __ ] I saw when we were
coming up and Spotify or when we took
over or Gambino or whatever maybe so
what happens is when you're good and you
get older what experience does is you're
like oh I seen this movie before so I'm
gonna run this blueprint
it was just nobody could be themselves
now now all of everybody can be them
actually that's why I love Atlanta and
Alana's got like 63 different things
going on there's a big difference
between childish gambino
and a little baby and Russ and like like
there's a million things going on here
like in itself forget about the culture
of the game itself within just in
Atlanta I grew up in the wine business
that's how great wine areas are there's
like a lot of different flavors in like
one little area that's what's going on
with Atlanta there's like all sorts of
[ __ ] going on
migos and few Philly there's these are
different sounds it but yeah man
honestly now that we're connected like
like DME or number right now on
Instagram yeah so funny so you like
standing right here you're like Santa
right here I'm like
it was all open Oh brick huh I said
stuffed amazing space you're what bored
look bored so people been in studio
I know unlimited right for the rest of
your life yeah you putting that up you
gonna put that up somewhere
[Laughter]
I appreciate that my god mama raised me
better never ever thought it'd come to
this no sense equals [ __ ] with no
sense [ __ ] around and get your dope kick
but you posted to the gig we rummage
into your crib look for the prized
possesions better hide
he's got a chip on my shoulder 2010
[Music]
trying to come up with and hold schools
with my hose we all hate for trouble for
nothing
yo crib I don't know
we currently live the yeah
the homies we scheming trying to come up
[Music]
my god
how are you baby for you
together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I can do
[Music]